the Oscar goes to
since the Oscars began nearly 90 years
ago there have been only 15
african-american winners in the acting
categories 15 as Hollywood prepares for
this year's Academy Awards there is a
huge outrage on social media calling for
more diversity in Hollywood
i created the oscarssowhite hashtag
because all too often i did not see
either myself or by experience
represented in film what has made you
post this tweet and first place I was in
my family room just you know watching it
on you know one of our local news
morning shows because they broadcast
them every year and so I was in my
family room and just disappointed and so
I took to Twitter to vent my frustration
right there before I went to work that
day she could never have guessed what
happens next the hashtag took off to
become the top trending nationwide
leading up two hundred thousand tweets
per hour
not everyone agrees with Oscar so white
there is a lot of backlash like some
people pointing out the lack of white
players and professional American
basketball using the hashtag NBA so
black so do they have a point there are
no black owners of NBA teams just as
there are no black studio heads in
Hollywood so that that criticism really
falls on its face
my wish for the future is that my
children have the opportunity to see
people who look like them and people who
share their experience up on the big
screen and that it and that the
oscarssowhite hashtag becomes absolutely
irrelevant online activist April rain
will go on boycotting the Oscars
ceremony just like she did last year
instead of watching the awards she will
be watching and live tweeting a fell off
her choice with her huge Twitter
community